vous attendiez quelqu'un
oui j'attends quelqu'un merci
et
vous savez ça oui ça vas y toi oui oui
assis toi maqsoud et en fait ils étaient
punis
c'était sûr en même temps un mec qui
aime pas le foot et qui remarque-t-on
épilation sourcils basse forcément un
peu dire
et sinon ton voyage il paraît que c'est
magnifique istanbul de trop beau par
contre qu'est ce qu'ils attendent
non mais c'est vrai à temps son hyper
agressif
une salle est toujours là à tenir la
jambe pour deux dans des babouches et
des tapis j'en pouvais plus d'accord et
tard apporter des choses dont voyage des
souvenirs ouais j'ai chopé le peignoir
de l'hôtel ou brodés tout doux et tout
cela d'or c'est gentil non ça nous
intéresse pas allez dégage dégage dégage
dégage tu passeras le message à tous tes
cousins là haut tu disais que pour eux
c'est nous qui pue
qu'est ce que je disais ouais l'hôtel
odette le service était top nickel tu me
diras s'étaient tenus par des français
normal et l'école quelques employés 1
mais triés sur le volet très présentable
au bout de quelques jours je laissais
même les bijoux dans la chambre
rien n'a été volé ni don si toi tu avais
loin à metz n'a rien à voir ah oui
d'accord que les arabes qui veulent pas
déconner c'est bon on peut plus rien
dire aujourd'hui
aulas c'est comme ces féministes a
toujours à gueuler à monter sur leurs
grands chevaux ou à me sort par tous les
trous cas là mais moi c'est toi qui me
sort par tous les trous du site quand
les banques je peux pas laisser dire des
conneries pareilles
dont tu te calmes axoa mais j'en ai rien
à [ __ ] de saya pâture est calme axe où
je suis dit de la merde tu penses de la
merde t'es de la bière oui ça va pas
nous traiter comme ça je traite comme je
veux une [ __ ] sabine ah bah ouais
été choqué et pourtant je suis français
je suis blanc je suis triés sur le volet
et je te le dis tu me connaissent voilà
donc tu vas te faire cuire le cul avec
les idées de merde je me barre
attends attends moi je suis désolé moi
tu vraiment désolés vous pouvez arrêter
de m'appeler maxou ça me fout les nerfs
qu'est ce que vous voulez encore lé soin
d'expliquer c'est pour le boulot je suis
cliente mystère qui fut payé pour dire
des trucs horribles que je pense pas du
tour mattei bodies à l'épreuve les
tester et voir s'ils sont trop bas vous
avez gagné je suis pas pro d'ailleurs
c'est sûrement viré c'est toi qu'à
gagner je t'invite à dîner avec moi ce
soir au boulot ça met bien l'accent j'ai
envie de te connecter c'est gentil
oui ça m'intéresse pas je me sexuelle ah
bon vous aurais jamais pensé c'est
bizarre tu as l'air hyper normal quoi
tanguay non c'est pas vrai mais merci
j'ai failli tomber dans le panneau
mais max ou
présente unique j'ouvre donc combattre